the media just makes all of this
impossible it is so hard to figure out
who to trust people who could not point
out russia or ukraine on a map suddenly
know exactly what to do people who
couldn't tie their shoes if their shoes
were velcro you can't tie velcro but you
get the point uh they suddenly know
everything everyone's an expert in
russia and ukraine and everything else
i'm trying not to uh go over my pay
grade in any of this but just translate
some basic info to you actually by the
way later we're putting up later today
right the nikki haley interview that's
later today yeah i interviewed nikki
haley on friday
with a bit of uh to get sort of a broad
look at what's going on in ukraine nikki
haley of course who was the united
states ambassador
to the un uh during the trump
administration when we did not have
these wars uh so she talks about peace
through strength i also talked to her
about a lot of my libertarian beliefs so
i think you'll you'll dig it we'll check
that out a little bit later but it's
really hard to get an honest assessment
of anything and everybody is just
talking out of their asses but then i
saw this this video went viral over the
weekend this is ufc fighter bryce
mitchell and he's being asked about
russia and ukraine because apparently if
you're a ufc fighter or you're a plumber
or a politician
or you work at the geek squad at best
buy you have to have an opinion on
absolutely everything all the time and
you're not going to believe this but ufc
fighter bryce mitchell the guy's making
some sense to get your thoughts on the
whole russia and ukraine situation
you know um
here's my first starters i'm not going
nowhere to fight none of these wars for
these politicians i'm staying at home
and when the war comes to arkansas i
will dig my boots in the ground and i
will die for everything i love and i
will not retreat if this country is
invaded and
everybody's saying well we gotta we
gotta evacuate we gotta leave we got i
will not i will dig my boots in the
arkansas soil and i will fight for the
people that i love for the land that i
love and the way life that i love but
i'm not going overseas to fight
i don't know what's going on to be
honest brother i really don't there's so
much stuff and i don't think nobody
knows what's going on fully there's been
so much political corruption in that
area you got biden and his son making a
[ __ ] ton of money
off of uh and using our tax dollars to
bribe their people that's treasonous in
my opinion
so you got hunter biden and his son
using our tax dollars hey if if
ukrainian government if you don't do
this we're taking your tax dollars he
shouldn't be giving our tax dollars to
that country anyway we got veterans out
here sleeping on the street and you're
gonna give our freaking tax dollars to
these ukrainians and all i'd rather i
don't know what's going on over there
but i'm not going over there and
fighting and god bless anybody that's
over there is fighting and i hope that
this [ __ ] just gets solved and man i
don't like war
you know what i mean i don't want people
dying and all that stuff i don't want to
be but i don't know what's going on
there's so much stuff that i think
that's corrupted that we just don't know
what's truly going on over there and i
just i pray all those people are safe
there you have it people ufc fighter
bryce mitchell who i did not know of
until i saw this video making more sense
than pretty much anyone you're going to
see
on cnn or msnbc or half these other
places like what is really going on here
how did this war just explode and this
energy crisis just explode
just as covid was wrapping up just
before the state of the union just
months before the midterms as
everybody's angry at the democrats like
what really is going on here and more
interestingly what he says at just like
the very human level like i'm not going
there i live in arkansas if someone
attacks arkansas i'll defend that he
even hits on the corruption like the
deep level of corruption in ukraine and
that is not simping for russia if you
say that okay there is deep corruption
in ukraine we know you've all seen the
video a million times right the video of
biden bragging how he was going to
withhold u.s dollars from ukraine
unless they fired the prosecutor that he
wanted fired everyone has seen it we
also weren't allowed to talk about
hunter biden's laptop before the
election hunter biden who was basically
a crack addict who had no expertise
in the energy sector was getting an
awful lot of money
from a ukrainian energy company before
the election the guy had no expertise
whatsoever to be working for a ukrainian
energy company so bryce mitchell man you
make some sense you make some sense
you